So guys, you start building your list and you're like, well, there's not that many people
paying for Google ads.
There's a couple on Home Advisor, but should, like, what do I do and should I continue to
pursue this if there's not that many people paying for Google ads?
That is a really good question and I'm going to talk about that right now.
So I want you to have, like, think about it this way.
The first thing that you want to think about is, okay, you're in Utah, you're in Pennsylvania,
you're in California, wherever you're sitting, and you're probably searching for, you know,
these searches in a different state.
Maybe not, but most likely you are.
And so one of the reasons why you might not be seeing ads is because of where you're searching
from.
Now, that's not always the case, but that is sometimes the case.
So I'm going to recommend a couple of tools that you can use where you can put in the
search terms and you can put in the city and it's actually going to search it as if
you were there.
Okay, it's going to kind of, like, change your IP address, if you will, and it's going
to give you different search results, different ads are going to show up because it's going
to look like you're actually there.
So a couple of those tools, if you look at my screen here, a couple of those tools that
I'm going to recommend, I actually have never used this one, I kind of like it.
I'm not sure, it looks like there's a paid, like, you could do a free trial.
I got a couple of searches for free.
It was seranking.com, actually really cool.
Like that one a lot.
You could check that out.
You literally put in the keyword, you know, country's already there unless you are in
Australia, Canada, I don't care where you're at, you put in the country and then you put
in the location.
So that was cool.
I checked this box.
Another popular fan fave is the valentine.app.
That's one that's kind of an OG, if you want to check that one.
So a couple of tools that you can check out to change what it looks like your location
is to give you a different search result.
The next thing that I do is this.
That's number one.
Next thing that I do, if you keep following along with me here on the screen, is if you
type in the city that you're targeting, so let's say Queen Creek Concrete, and we go
to the map, I like to just look at this and go, okay, you know, obviously we're trying
to target these cities that no one else is necessarily, they're not on people's radar.
So Queen Creek, I don't know, it's right here.
So what are the cities and suburbs around that specific city we're targeting that are
bigger, maybe people, they're more on people's radar that people would be willing to drive
to?
So I'm going to start from here, I'm going to start typing in Concrete Chandler, Concrete
Gilbert, Concrete Mesa, Concrete Tempe, Concrete Scottsdale, even Concrete Phoenix, because
that is not that far.
A lot of these people, they advertise in Phoenix, but they're actually based down here.
The majority of the people I know and have talked to in the businesses I work with, they
don't live in Glendale and Phoenix proper.
They live down in the southeast corner with Chandler, Gilbert, Mesa, Tempe, Queen Creek,
they live down there anyway.
So what I would then start doing is after you look at the valentine.app, some of these
other tools, I would then just go use your same keywords and look at nearby cities,
because if there's a business that's in Chandler, that's not a very far drive, and that's almost
like a neighborhood, that's like a little suburb, if you will.
So those are the first two things that I would do.
Here's what you need to do.
Ultimately, though, this is what it comes down to, is you need to make a decision.
Let's say you do this, let's say you just still can't find anyone on Google Ads, or
there's maybe one person, or there's one person, but you're like, I don't know, maybe they're
a lead gen company, whatever, but there are people on Home Advisor, but there's just not
a lot of people paying for Google Ads.
You need to make a decision.
I will tell you this, it is possible to sell to somebody who is not paying for Google Ads
or advertising.
Yes, I have done it, there are many, many people that have done that.
And before I discovered how much easier this was, that's all that I did.
So yes, it is possible.
And so here's the decision you need to make, is you need to make the decision, especially
if it's your first deal, is this worth the squeeze?
Because you can turn any website that is producing leads into money if you try hard enough.
But I'm looking at opportunity cost.
So what I look at is, okay, given the situation, given this specific niche and city location,
is this worth going after at this time?
And here's kind of the rule of thumb that I would give you.
If this, for me personally, if I find a city like Queen Creek, and you guys watched me
do the due diligence, and it was absolutely ridiculously low-hanging fruit, there was
no competition, there was Steve, Steve Wood, or Steve whatever, that didn't even have a
website and he was showing up for everything, I mean, there was nothing, no competition,
and there's search volume, and there's CPC.
For me, where I'm at in my business, I'm going for it, I'm just full-setting, baby, I'm going.
If this is your very first deal, however, my advice to you is if this is your first
deal, and you do all this, and you cannot find people that are paying for Google Ads
after you've done the valentine.app and these different tools, you've looked at nearby cities,
and you're just not seeing that many options, my advice to you is skip it, earmark it, dog,
whatever that term is, put it on the back burner, save it for later, and go find another
one because the game is you gotta get your first deal, that's what we gotta do, no matter
what that looks like, no matter what opportunities you have to avoid, what opportunities you
have to pass up, we want you to get your first deal, because that first deal is gonna get
you the confidence, that first deal is gonna get that mental barrier removed, that first
deal is gonna lead to the second deal, the third deal, the fourth, the fifth, so my advice
to you is if this is your first deal, and you start looking around, and there's just
no one paying for ads that you can find, and you've done a lot of searching, you've tried
all the different apps and tools and nearby cities, skip it, put it on the back burner,
and come back, I want you getting your first deal, I want you to go into a city where there
are hungry business owners, if you're somebody that has multiple deals, if you're somebody
that is making a decent amount of money, and you see a city like this, like in my case,
I am going to go for it anyway because I can afford to lose a little bit of money, I can
afford to go in and run the risk of there's no one that wants to pay for ads because it's
such a good opportunity that it's worth the risk for me, but if you don't have a deal,
or you really need that first deal, my advice to you is save it, skip it, and we'll come
back to it.